RTX 3090 and a 20 core 13 gen 13 980 HX
versus the M2 Max does it even have a
chance well today we'll find out because
not only are we going to be running some
benchmarks like you've seen but we're
gonna run real world performance tests
including photo editing video editing 3D
rendering regular workflows and much
more and we'll find out if the M2 Max
gets smoked this is the MSI Titan
gt77hx and it is an absolute Beast of a
machine you guys see how big it is look
at that huge backhand sticking out of it
that is full of heat sinks and fins in
there to cool this thing down this thing
has four fans with eight heat pipes
compared to the Mac which has two fans
and two small ones yeah has a 330 watt
power adapter that has not only way
larger than Apple's 140 but also thicker
as well now as you guys see I had to
stack the MacBook on top of another
MacBook just to get the displays to
match up for you guys because this thing
is fairly thick now MSI advertises it as
fairly thin for such a beast it's about
one inch but because of the layout and
the shape it is thick and it weighs
pretty much double what the MacBook 16
inch weighs now inside we do have a 99.9
watt hour battery just like the M2
16-inch MacBook Pro but of course this
thing sucks powered that performance so
not only are we gonna test it plugged in
with this beefy cable but I'm gonna run
a few tests unplugged to see do we still
get massive performance drops when we
unplug like with the previous generation
Intel and Nvidia chips or can it
maintain that better and how does it
compare here the full specs side by side
we have a 5.6 gigahertz 20 core I9
processor 64 gigabytes of ultra fast Ram
the RTX 4090 has its own 16 gigs of RAM
and yes this MSI costs 4 700 compared to
3 500. now if you take the MacBook when
you upgrade it to 64 gigs of RAM 2
terabytes of SSD we're up to 4 300
meaning it's still quite a bit less
money now the screens also fairly nice
it's 144 Hertz 4K mini LED 1000 nit but
you guys can see that the contrast
levels don't match up because this has a
matte coating over the top of it but
enough about specs let's go ahead and
jump into performance I have geekbench 5
open it actually looks like we have 24
cores compared to 12 and double the ram
let's go ahead and run the CP view
Benchmark we do have best performance
enabled on the Windows laptop can you
guys hear the fans are already spinning
up where here the fans are off all right
guys we have the results and look at
this as far as single core we are almost
identical the MSI is half a percent
faster but multi-core it is 37
higher score so that is definitely
impressive now what I'm curious about
it'll be my first time testing this I'm
going to unplug this bad boy set it to
best performance and let's try this one
more time now of course the MacBook was
unplugged the whole time that's one
thing I like about them the performance
stays the same let's wait for this to
get done it does seem like it's taking
longer than before and I'm not hearing
the fans this time around all right
we're getting the score
oh my goodness gracious the single core
stayed about the same so it's still
beating out the MacBook by a little bit
but the multi-core score is at 12
656 instead of over 20 000. that's a
huge drop it was 36 faster before now
the MacBook is 21 faster that is
probably one of the biggest swings in
performance that I have ever seen so now
we know if you buy one of these bad boys
you best keep it plugged in now I want
to run the compute test we've been
skipping this lately because we have
Windows Mac OS we have metal we have
Cuda but they're still doing the same
exact tasks just using their respective
apis and Graphics so let's go ahead and
run that all right wow we have 86 000
compared to
800 literally three times the perform
and we'll see how that applies to real
world productivity tasks now the ssds in
this MSI are insane they are almost
twice as fast as the MacBook in terms of
re-speed and not because they are in
raid zero now I want to test the web
responsiveness I'm going to run
speedometer 2.0 here and this just
checks the performance of web browsing
and a lot of applications are now web
based so it shows the performance and
this is somewhat surprising because you
guys saw the single core score here is
faster the multi-core is way faster
we're plugged in but the MacBook still
won by 18
which is pretty interesting now this is
still a very fast score but wow and
we're on battery now one such web
application is figma for design and this
project right here is brought To Us by
500 designs one of the best design
agencies in LA and I'm zooming in here
on the MacBook everything's insanely
smooth loads up really quickly I'll zoom
in right here you guys see pixelated bam
second later it's all done let's try out
the same thing on this
machine
as you guys can see right there that
took about three seconds or so to load
up just like my Mac Pro which also has
the Intel processor and that's very
weird because this has way way more
performance let's try that again another
spot
once again
multiple seconds to load up we're on the
same internet uh everything's exactly
the same so I wonder if it's got to do
with Apple's unified memory which just
can communicate faster and I have these
12 high resolution web pages selected
and we're going to go ahead and Export
these all right both are finished the
MacBook took a minute 35 seconds very
fast but the MSI took a minute and 31
seconds beating It Out by four seconds
so it's a mix back when we're rendering
it is slightly faster but as far as
responsiveness and design you guys saw
the difference now in this next test I
think the Mac is gonna get destroyed
we're gonna max out the CPUs we're gonna
look at the temperatures we're gonna
look at how much power these systems
require and what performance we get but
first let me tell you guys about moth's
brand new foldable five in one sit and
stand laptop desk the moft Z not only is
it super thin and with really good build
quality but it is the only stand that
offers both a Sit and Stand posh sure in
a one-piece design and you guys see how
quick it is to set this up and we can
use this 16 inch MacBook Pro and I can
stand up bam I'm all good to use it and
then we could drop it down and set it up
in a 25 35 45 or even a 60 degree angle
for iPads so go ahead and check out the
moft Z using the link in the video
description below and now let's go ahead
and get started with our cinebench test
now right away I am seeing a hundred or
two 200 Watts on the CPU my goodness I
mean it's at 190 now 170 it's scaled
down the Mac hit about 36 or so at Peak
it's running at 34 and a half right now
it hit 96 degrees Celsius right away our
Mac is still 87 with the fans off so
this thing definitely gets hot very fast
we're running at 3.7 3.8 gigahertz
compared to 3.2 on the Mac and now it
Throttle Down to 2.7 2.8 gigahertz and
then the fans kicked up loud uh to try
to get that performance back up it's
very interesting they actually did try
to keep the fans being quiet listen to
this
it's about to take off and it's back to
140 Watts right there 145 wow I have
never seen this in a laptop now to be
fair the Mac is at 101 degrees Celsius
but the fans are literally I don't know
20 up Apple doesn't care if it runs hot
they want it to be quiet and it is
silent at this fan speed let's break out
the thermal Cam and it looks like we
have about 40 41 degrees over here
that's not too bad
definitely not too bad and on the Mac 42
slightly higher so this Beast is doing a
great job cooling down 130 140 Watts
sustained uh but it's just very loud oh
my goodness guys you know what I'm not
gonna show this let's let the MacBook
catch up all right it is done I got 13
500 like you've seen before and I did
the math on the points per watt the
MacBook got 400 score per watt that it
used and on it's on battery and the MSI
got
205 points per what but because it used
so much more power it got a score of 27
573 I can't even say that that is insane
it is literally twice the performance
with four times more power usage but
it's still a laptop that is insanity now
since I'm curious I'm gonna unplug it I
want to see what we get on battery power
I'm going to clear out my minimal and
maximums let's go ahead and do just a
single test since I know it's not going
to throttle and dang this time we only
used
50.99 that is 51 Watts basically a
quarter of the power that we did before
still more than the Mac it's running at
about 45 Watts now and only at about 2.1
gigahertz and yes high performance mode
is on and here we go look at that 15
788. this shows the new capability of
the 13 gen now it did drop in
performance by A Lot close to double but
it used only slightly more power than
the MacBook did it stayed silent and it
outperformed it that is impressive and
also showed where the graphics I'm going
to start out with 3D Marks Wildlife
extreme Unlimited it this RTX 4090 is a
beast so let's go ahead and run this
test all right we have our results here
our MacBook got 150.7 but the MSI got
260 frames per second that's way higher
but if we do the math that is 72 percent
more frames per second which is a big
difference compared to geekbench where
it literally tripled the MacBook now uh
this is a gaming Benchmark it's well
optimized for both systems so it shows
you when it's optimized the difference
isn't as big now I also ran it unplugged
and there it dropped to 64 being less
than half of what the MacBook got so you
literally get a quarter of the
performance on battery and I was
honestly hoping for better with this new
uh RTX 4000 series and that was going
into the settings and turning off all
the battery saving features that are
there the moral of the story is make
sure this thing is plugged in no matter
what not only when you're rendering if
you're using graphics performance it's
going to be very weak if you're not
plugged in and now let's look at 3D
rendering where the MSI using Opti X
meaning it's going to use the ray
tracing course to do this is going to be
insanely fast we're going to go ahead
and render this we're using metal with
the mac and the Mac did get a lot faster
with these latest updates but let's see
what we get wow okay this thing did it
so fast I don't even know if it peaked
the graphics use the 131 Watts 5.4
seconds compared to 30 Watts Peak 21.8
seconds now we got to do something
harder so I opened up party tug here I
will let it load up somehow the Mac
loaded it faster even though I started
it after okay both these are done and
let's hit render wow guys this is
mind-blowingly fast if you need a laptop
and you did 3D round hearing oh my
goodness we have a minute and four
seconds compared to
13.6 seconds that is more than four
times faster rendering performance Apple
you really need to get ray tracing in
these and now let's get into photo
editing using Lightroom which uses both
a CPU and the GPU I'm going to go in
here and it says it supports limited
performance so let's go to custom and
we're going to enable to use full
performance the first thing I'm going to
try is some of their AI tools so let's
select Sky detection
the Mac surprisingly faster there uh it
was almost instant less than a second
here about two seconds or so and that
might be just because of the neural
engine that's built into here let's try
the subject detection here
the Mac slightly faster there this one
wasn't that far behind the next I'm
going to do is compile a panorama so I'm
going to import these photos we have 10
50 megapixel images here the Mt Max took
42 seconds and of course this thing has
a crazy fast SSD which will help so
let's run it the fans are kicking up
here and Bam
36 seconds for this thing that is 16
faster I was expecting more because we
are plugged in the CPU smoked it double
the performance the graphics is way more
powerful too it's very interesting now
for the render I had to do something
tougher so here I have 499 photos
instead of just 50 that I normally do
I'm dropping at the same time
Mac loaded up a little quicker it also
got the previews faster as well I'm
going to apply preset to all of these so
the graphics has something to do now I'm
not doing the Adaptive One because then
the neural engine is going to Edge out
the PC here all right wow the Mac is
going fast I honestly was not expecting
that because this thing has better
performance in every way twice SSD okay
that's crazy this is done this thing's a
turbo fan about to take off the fans are
off here I guess that's unified
architecture I don't know but now I'm
gonna go ahead and set this up to export
all 499 of these images I'll let it cool
down a little bit here and then we will
export all right wow guys here we're
using 85 percent of our CPU 45 of the
graphics and the max is using all of the
graphics and as far as CPU performance
scores are almost maxed out efficiency
cores are kind of chilling there halfway
wow 96 100 percent of the CPU and we
look like we're neck and neck here with
this race no no no I spoke too soon this
thing's kicking up the fans speeding up
we're using 12 gigs of RAM on the
graphics card here bam it is done and we
have to wait for the Mac I'm not sure
why this thing's slowing down the
performance cores are half the graphics
is half but winning is winning and the
Windows PC took two minutes and 53
seconds compared to 3 minutes and 58 and
now let's test out video editing now if
DaVinci Resolve 18 open up right here
which is very well optimized for both
and the first thing I'm going to look at
is the performance of denoising raw
video which is super tough on these
laptops it's going to show the raw
performance of these systems so I'm
going to go ahead and hit play and wow
her MacBook is playing back at about 13
frames per second which is good for a
laptop but I have never seen a laptop
played back at a perfect 24 FPS meaning
we can actually go into our timeline
here and play it back in real time with
no glitches or stuttering with a bunch
of denoising enabled my 15 000 Mac Pro
can't do this that has a twenty hundred
dollar Vega professional graphics card
in it but this laptop is legitimately a
desktop replacement as long as you can
plug it in of course but where else can
you get this now the graphics card is
almost maxed out here so you can get
more performance than this but that is
insane and now I have a standard 4K
graded project here this is h.265 which
is what 95 of people are shooting
neither of these have any issues playing
this back and I want to see how much
graphics card usage we have and that is
very interesting we have 26 27
on the Nvidia and then only about 10 to
on the MacBook meaning the MacBook
actually has more overhead for extra
effects titles animations but that's
very odd and now I'm going to render
this five minute test project using
h.265 we're using nvidia's encoders and
I really want to see did they make a
good improvement with the 4000 series
let's click render now the Nvidia is
fast about 125 frames per second but the
MacBooks at
165 and with that it's only using 56 of
the graphics compared to a hundred
percent here so yes Nvidia did get
faster
but no it is not enough the MacBook just
smoked it it is so fast and so good for
video editing now these numbers here are
just hilarious you can't complain about
this 59 seconds compared to 45 for a
five minute project that is insanely
fast of course we're plugged in over
here just as a curiosity let's re-render
that I want to see how much it slows
down and that took a minute and 52 so
not twice as long but close and about
the performance of an M1 MacBook Air at
least for this kind of work now of
course you guys saw denoising it was
massively better and because of that I
have to give it something harder to do
something where the fans are spinning up
so this is 6k black magic raw footage
that needs to be debared it's scaled we
have a color grade on here and let's
render this well it's definitely much
harder we're running at 70 FPS on the
Windows laptop at a hundred percent
graphics usage forty percent CPU and on
the Mac we're also maxing out the
graphics using even more of the CPU but
we're getting 135 frames per second it
is blowing through this footage 55
seconds on the MacBook
I was not expecting this because the
Windows laptop took a minute 44 seconds
almost twice as long in this tougher
test than before before it was very
close
I just did not expect that at all and we
are plugged in compared to on battery
power so turns out if you do video
editing unless you're denoising with
heavy footage with heavy denoising the
Mac
does a killer job plus you have the
prores encoders and decoders so that you
can work with produce Pros footage and
it's even faster than this so you guys
let me know your thoughts obviously for
gaming it blew it away
3D rendering destroy the MacBook but for
photo editing for video editing for web
tasks uh just in general a cheaper
system 3 500 bucks compared to 4 700
were specs worse standard benchmarks uh
but real world was doing a killer job
now personally I'm excited to see msi's
other laptops this thing is huge I want
to see their creator z16p that's a great
comparison uh with price with size I
want to see how that compares maybe some
other Alternatives so if you guys want
to see those make sure you guys click
subscribe because we are going to get
more in and we'll run some other tests
for you guys and see how a laptop that's
similar size will compare click one of
those videos right over there and I'll
see you in the next one
foreign